what made you want to tell this story
especially from
where the story begins
well i thought it was a stronger version
of what power was period to me like when
we were creating
the power series i
i was looking around and that and the
black mafia family bmf was the uh
a version of it that was
wasn't a fictional story
you know and the intensity of it like
because the culture is aware of it like
they know it
like there's been so many mentions in
music culture a big meech and different
different references
and music that um
it made it one of the projects that
would be a good project for me to get my
hands on to develop and
i had the right stuff for about two
years before i sold the stars
so
i this project is ran for about four and
a half years so it's been
four and a half years since i sold to
what was the conversation like with big
meech about bringing his story to the
screen
well you know what it's
they trust me
you know the person
they personally have a relationship with
me where they know if it's in my hands
it's going to be done right they say
well
if we can get him to focus on it we'll
get it done faster because he can get it
done like they're just saying
if you say you're going to do it give it
to him don't go could we give it to
somebody else and then we're not sure
what we're going to end up with
you know
they just they just knew early on that
if i said i'm gonna do it it's gonna get
time
how did you know that casting demetrius
was
the way to go that he was the guy that's
got to play his his own dad
like you know what i i just work
i did uh
dinner thieves i just worked with o'shea
uh you know his ice cube son
and
he
is really good but he o'shea
was is a trained actor like he's he's
been in school
in in school of the arts since he can
think of what's going on you know what
i'm saying
and when when i went through the the
process of uh
when i saw the first the the draft of
who was that i was like oh so he's like
17 like cause we tell an origin story
i'm like who am i get to play that so i
hired uh
a casting
like in la i hired the cast and cast to
get
an idea or a sense of who we would be
looking for to
like who would be the names that would
be available because even if i if i had
to get to them and commit to them
earlier
i'll get them committed to it to the
project because
if we waited it
timing may make it fall and it's not as
important as it could be to the actual
person if i had reached out to him in
advance i'd be able to get him on board
for the project and then we looked
around and i couldn't find i couldn't
find a person so
i'm looking at meech because he came he
wanted to play playing music
so his idea was to go and make music and
do some different things and i'm looking
and i'm like nah this is not it do this
yeah and i sent him
i sent him to california i you know i
took care of his housing out there and
i put him in school
in in acting school and then
he
he did the work man when he came he came
back because he did have to take put
himself on tape for the
that the job and
he had we had an experience where it was
a bad tape because
the his acting coach at the time had
someone else
direct him
to
direct his performance to tape
and
he following the instructions and didn't
do as good as he could do
and then later we had him do it again
and
got him into position for him to
actually work on the project he got the
job
uh davinci just told me that he was he
had a moment with you where you said to
him like
basically you are grateful to him
because if
this show did well and he was right guy
for this this helped your career out
right and he and he felt grateful for
that when you're when you're putting a
show together like this and you're
casting people
is it part of your thought process that
you've got this younger generation that
you know they looked up to you they know
you
but you're helping them get on as well
is that part of the process for you
absolutely is like what he's telling you
is
i i make them they get so excited about
me
because i want them to understand that
they're transcending me also
i said when this works because you've
done the work
i need to show to be a success as much
as you need to show to be a success
all right and when it kind of pulls me
to a different staging position and what
i do next because
the the networks don't question
creatively my ideas when i've had this
idea for
six years ahead of them
and it's successful they go well what
else do we got laying around because we
need it
what is one show driving the success of
that network
so
being able to i don't think the projects
work with one good person
a collective
piece all the time like and in raising
kanan i i
i got uh
patina miller i got joey badass i got
all my apps i got a ma i got a real
squad over there and then i'm built a
similar
competitive this this show is
look sasha pin is the writer show runner
for raising kanan he's concerned about
bmw he looks and goes
wait a minute
what is like what is did you see with
the whole show did you he's like though
is it good good like you know because
they look and they go when raising kanan
becomes the new number one
on the network
i'm gonna consistently topped the work
that i've delivered
because
it's getting easier it's it's a foul
shot for me now
you know what i'm saying to make a
successful project so i'm looking going
i got the group i know how what i'm
doing what i'm trying to accomplish with
these projects and
it's
i think people are starting to see that
i'm executing it with no problem
it's interesting to be in a position
where your own you are your own biggest
competition
yeah
you want to but it's like that my entire
music career is the same way
if you got one guess what you need to
turn it off you got to hit record turn
it off why you need another one
you need another song you need another
id is that good you need to find new
production that
so you can follow up with that hit so
when i when i'm
having power i'm already thinking how do
i
raise the intensity or or have a story
that
there's some similarities to it the
choice of of going down
within this the lifestyle the fast life
or or
that that energy and that puts danger
into it
so if you're looking at like as far as
family because they really family films
it's just
the journey of
of people choices in in the cities that
are a little more extreme than
traditional
family stories you know yeah
you got snoop in this you got m in this
and this is a detroit story what was it
like a no-brainer when you told them hey
i'm doing this if they wanted to come on
board did they ask you did you ask them
right episode seven i directed snoop's
portion performance of the whole
series for
his for that episode seven and the
episode ahead of that
like i shot saying
um
i got em to come out to perform as right
boy rick for me and then we use the
the uh effects that they used in um
on de niro and uh the irishman
of course like we got we used that stuff
to
to bring him back down into uh his youth
to play white boy rick in his teens
so like the idea just it popped into my
head but it really was randy's idea
randy hodges the writer show runner he
was like yo
if you could just do we could just get
one thing like something is just like
this just like big you said you did
everything else because i had
the music like everybody is
giving me what i needed to make this
project
a super success like bmf is the only uh
television show that we have an entire
soundtrack for
the other the shows i do the theme song
and
that would be enough of a a new musical
connection
and um
this one
i got music from asha i got music from
chris brown i got music from her i got
music from
so many talented artists that when
you're here it's gonna blow your head
off like it's like
yeah
you know the series will end and because
it was like the 90s
and and in the 80s when you was watching
the show
when it goes to black then the music
will play and you'll hear something
that's a record for right now
you know
that's it well man thank you so much for
this time congratulations again on the
project i'm looking forward also to uh
expendables 4 having been a big fan of
50 bulletproof on xbox i want to see you
in action so
this is going
i got i'm training hard man they got me
working